- Vegas, Vegas knows how
to fuck you in the ass.
What?
(rock music)
Vegas.
I'm out here once a
month at the Riviera,
trying to sneak my new
stuff for the TV show,
but you know, they're
excited, weekend Vegas crowds,
they can kind of smell it when
it's not polished material.
And I'm like,
what do you guys
think about trees?
So you know how trees are
like tall or whatever?
OK, well, like what doesn't
bend breaks? (CHECK AGAIN)
Stop cutting off my great jokes.
We can't hear your voice on
this show or maybe we will.
Kim, my sister, has
never been to Vegas.
I feel like she's gonna love it.
- Ow.
- You should take your
ring off, so people,
no actually keep it on.
Two of you, two of
us, I'll do the math.
We're in Vegas having fun.
I know what's going
to get you psyched up.
You can drink outside.
- Do you want to
wear one of my rings,
and then people will think
that we are both
married and happy?
- Do you know where we
can get tested for AIDS?
- [Stranger] Huh?
- AIDS?
- Yeah.
It doesn't have to be
blood it could be...
A clinic, alright thank you.
You need another drink.
Come on this is the best.
- No, I know, I know.
- Cheers.
Cheers queers.
- It's more, it's more
phallic than architecture.
- That makes it phallic,
you jamming your straw
in and out of it,
you fucking pervert.
I am fucking wasted right now.
Like, look where I am,
look where you are.
- Cuz I'm worried, like
I want to still seem
like I'm a lady.
- Drink it,
I feel like a dick head.
- How come nobody's
trying to fuck us.
- We should probably
take it easy on these.
- I'm gonna throw this up.
- Drink your Eiffel Tower.
- Babe, it's hard.
(trumpets)
- [Amy] That's beautiful.
I don't care what your
sexuality is, that's beautiful.
- Babe, you have a show tonight,
maybe slow down a little bit.
- I have a show tonight.
- You have a show tonight.
You could just stop
drinking all together.
- Oh I'll stop
drinking, you're right.
Stop drinking, start dancing.
(dance music)
- Shh.
I might get sick.
Hold my hair.
Not you.
Sir, sir.
Sir.
- It seems like
maybe you'll do OK.
- I'm not drunk, you're drunk.
- I thought that Vegas
would be a really
good place to come.
- What is this, water?
Is this water?
This tastes like water.
- Ready.
- I wish I was going faster.
Oh, shit.
I have no control.
Do you have a basket?
You know what, I'm gonna
bring these back to my room
and then I'm going to come
back and pay for them.
Sir, please don't yell at me,
my father never loved me.
(piano music)
Hi.
I picked you up this
coffee, I thought
it would be helpful for
you, for just right now.
- I'm not drunk.
You're, OK, yeah.
Thank you.
I think that's coffee.
(light jazz music)
- [Announcer] Ladies
and gentlemen,
give it up for Amy
Schumer, let her hear it.
(audience applauds)
- Who said it, is it this guy?
You fucking Vegas
tan piece of shit.
(audience laughs)
With your hot girlfriend
who will leave you
the second some
95-year-old winks at her
who has a dollar more than you.
(audience laughs)
I hope you die alone.
So,
and also to answer
your question,
it's to make dicks
like yours seem big.
(audience cheers)
Thank you guys so
much for coming out.
You were a great crowd.
(rock music)
- Just write what you
would like to have
appear around you.
We wanted puppies around
us, and we got them.
- [Amy] Like, there are just
moments where you're like,
oh my God, we wrote this,
it's really happening now.
- [Director] That's your queue.
(cast and crew laugh)
(rock music)
(sharp noise)